React can render lists from arrays, you need JavaScript's map method, that's it.
Call array.map, pass a function, return JSX, react renders one element per item.
Each list item needs a key prop.
Keys help React track which items changed, were added or removed.
Keys must be unique among siblings, they don't need to be globally unique, just within
that list.
You stable ID from your data as keys, database ID are ideal.
Don't use array indexes as keys unless the list never changes order.
Index keys break when items move.
Never use math.random as a key.
It changes every render and destroys performance.
Keys are not passed as props.
If your component needs the ID, pass it as a separate prop with a different name.
You can filter and map together.
Call array.filter first, then dot map on the results.
JSX lets you embed the whole map expression inside curly braces, right in the return statement.
If your list items need more than one DOM element, wrap them in a fragment.
Fragments let you add a key without adding extra DOM nodes.
Nested lists work the same way.
Map inside map, each with its own key.
Act shows a warning in the console if keys are missing.
Take it seriously, it means list updates will be slow or incorrect.
Let's recap, use map to render lists, give every item a stable key, avoid indexes and
random values.
Next up, keeping components pure.